sono anni che vorrei una ragazza e cosa
fare io non so all'improvviso e dai
pasti gira un improvvisato
grazie ragazzi venitemi concerti mastai
mississippi è un fiume bello grossissimo
più grosso dei buoni ma perché volevo
fare un intro del video frigga stipati
compreso lo zio punto zio toni torna
battisti ha un valore dello zio toni
fermi tutti
mentre sto montando questo video è un
caso incredibile che io abbia mio zio
toni in casa perché sono qua a torino
vediamo che cosa ne pensa zio toni di
questa scena c'era tantissimo zio toni
ok ragazzi la reazione c'era direi che
possiamo riprendere con il blog che sto
montando in questo momento quindi
[Musica]
siamo pronti per in mano come il rambo
disceso con lei poi uno si chiede che
cazzo afam i turisti quando vanno in
america fotografano le scale ma che
cazzo fotografi le scale da lì sarà
sicuramente di un criminale con uno
sbirro è vero buongiorno ragazzo validi
tutto bene
siamo svegliati ha una fame della
madonna ha detto a mangiare in questo
posto che il più conosciuto di new
orleans problema e questo per entrare al
caffè di un monde
porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] io avevo
fame carcare katana e poi all'improvviso
venne attirato da un sono familiare
solerte che avevo già sentito un
qualcosa di rettamente italiano
all
cg dai cannoli sì stiamo inseguendo
quell'omino laggiù che in teoria era
l'ex keen sword record credo per l'uomo
più alto del mondo che storia almeno è
simpatico signore signore aspè come si
dice in francese dalle dimensioni le mag
de milan ma come fai a fare spiega mm
mag di milano come fatto fare questa
cosa spiega ma perché c'era ma non ci
voglio credere
è così che si rimorchia la patata
secondo lorenzo e indovina qual è la
battuta che sto per fare maghetti guarda
fortuna spassa la mia ex
[Musica]
stavo per fare una foto sulle rotaie poi
ho visto cose che passavo detto no no
guarda lì a fuori a rifar video con fede
e malati i sabati da fare colazione e
c'erano queste cose bellissime dovrebbe
essere cioccolato con all'interno
del march medium quindi lo testeremo in
questo momento davanti a voi vi faccio
sapere poi come mi ha comprato anche la
macchina sempre per questa occasione
molto importante molto importante certo
è buonissimo
è buonissimo è vero
ma non assaggiare prima che de rose
grandi tutto allora ragazzi questo è il
test per vedere se arrivi alla
schiacciata quindi tu salti e poi di
colpire quel coso rosso e se lo colpisci
vuol dire che sei bravo a fare le
schiacciate adesso proviamo subito a
parte
[Musica]
sbaglio o quello dietro riflettore che
porta di una [ __ ] ciò sempre la sfiga
nera che ci sembrava tutto in avanti e
veramente joe jonas
questa roba consiste nel dribblarsi
tutti sti cosi centrare il buco che non
è capace quest'uomo so più bravo io a
centrare i buchi prendere la altra palla
correre a canestro schiacciare tornare
nell'altro canestro e rifare canestro
non è capace
ha vinto lui che non centrava il buco
questa si chiama la skills challenge
perché anche loro sotto sotto fanno il
click day
ma cos'è ma cos'era
[Musica]
entrato fra tesi pronto di suoi
scaldando si pronto o il culo alle bron
devi fare il culo sì ma con tutto
vacalebre siamo nel campo
questo lo stadio camp nou del barcellona
madonna quanto bene ragazzi miliardi
live ma tom frate guarda quanto ben di
dio guarda li guarda li togli di zia
eccolo eccolo l'uomo della mia vita io
non pago affitto lopalco affitto stiano
faccio pry o non pago affitto no non
farmi zoomare su john legend anch'io so
cantare come john legend of john nota mi
cazzo ma perché c'è anche beyoncé me
come in champions e a un metro da me ma
che significato ha per lei jane si
[Applauso]
chiama l'interrogazione non sei un cazzo
negli sguardi
[Applauso]
allora adesso io non è che voglio fare
sempre pignolo che deve sempre dire la
cosa che non va ma beyoncé che cazzo cha
da sventolarsi col ventaglio che fa
veramente un freddo cane con l'aria
condizionata ci vanno pesantissimi
lancia ha le palle che noi non avremmo
prendiamo e ce l'abbiamo fatta ma questi
giorni che ci proviamo
tre giorni
e o non è firmata parliamo
dio è firmata dico
il tesoro e [ __ ] firmata casa
comunque sono tre giorni che ci proviamo
a fare questa cosa non siamo riusciti a
vai a prendere una cazzo di palla
michele non ci possiamo in grado cioè
quell'uomo lì che sta provando a
corrompere le guardie per entrare a
salutare gt non ce la farà mai nella
vita
ora che avete visto lorenzo no
eccolo eccolo eccolo qua io ho preso
bene basta la carriera da youtuber
giugno a basket a [ __ ] i video la
cosa brutta di di non avere una
videocamera accesa 24 ore su 24
mi sono appena fatto una rampa di scale
ma una rampa raga non tuscany un'altra
fatto una rampa di scale cadendo dalle
scale davanti a tutta questa gente
tutta mi sono fermata dopo dieci scalini
in caduta è stato non mi sono fatto
niente però è stato sarà bella
esperienza
allora che siamo in aereo siamo a new
orleans mondo vanta poi la gente a
trattare dg e poi da parigi
stavamo scorrendo i film che ci sono
sull'aereo
questo aereo americano si presume ci sia
la cinematografia americana
scorro i film e invece
maghetti
ok